yeah yeah the nonprofits do good work I
mean this is my experience at Venture
for America really proud of everything
we did um but one reason I ran for
president was that I actually started
Venture for America because I wanted to
create a functional economy yeah which
sounds like I should start a nonprofit
like I want to help people yeah and uh
and so and I determined that in order to
start a functional economy you would
need to change a lot of things that the
a nonprofit never will be able to Yes uh
and so you need to have a functional
government and so I'm still on the
functional government train I believe
it's the highest leverage thing we can
do even though it's very difficult and
arduous uh um but it's the only genuine
answer and uh one of the things I
suggest to People by the way a lot of
philanthropists are wising up to this
yeah is like look let's say you're going
to pump millions of dollars into
education uh like you know what's not
going to change is our education all
outcomes unless you actually had a
better educational system how do you get
a better educational system there's
similar with climate change it's like
hey you're going to putp millions of
dollars into climate change you know
what would help with that like a
government that was doing various things
so this so this becomes the highest
leverage move you can make even though
again like people and a lot of people
it's like oh politics want to stay away
it's like look I get it I hate politics
too yeah but if we're going to try and
solve the biggest problems
meaningfully that's how someone like me
winds up running for president that's
how someone like me winds up starting
the forward party uh and and so we're
trying to make the good things happen
now you have taken different Tech which
is something that I a th% endorse and
support and am uh an investor in and a
board member of and very helpful but you
identified a problem and then started a
benevolent B Corp to try and solve that
problem and create a win-win win so what
is the problem and then what the heck is
Samar so let me back go back up one step
and that
essentially my takeaways both before I
joined the the campaign then during the
campaign and even now in starting Samar
is that doing good by the numbers and
also my personal experience it's not in
great shape and don't get me wrong
there's amazing nonprofit organizations
I love that do fantastic work and I want
to be very we got to be very clear here
we're not talking about if if you're a
nonprofit executive listening to this
you're like wait my organization does
incredible work screw you Zach you don't
know what you're talking about that's
not what I'm talking about what I'm
talking about is the institution and it
systems um and the numbers are the proes
in the pudding um household giving is
down um and has been declining now some
of that's economy related but percentage
of households as a whole giving is going
down as well amount of Americans
volunteering massively declining we all
say we want You' asked somebody do you
want to volunteer this year are you
going to volunteer this year the answer
is yes Almost 100% of people say yes I'm
going to volunteer that's like are you
an question um we all say yes no
I'm not no I'm not a jerk yes I'm going
to volunteer the reality is one in four
people will volunteer this year um
that's it's kind of the same thing you
see with companies we say we're doing
awesome things but the reality is we got
to make money well well part of the
reason why so few people will actually
volunteer is that you're not sure your
time's going to be uh well utilized like
you show up and a lot of these organs
would be like narf you know like no
one's fault yes but uh you know just I I
mean I I actually volunteered for a
nonprofit as a 20-some year old and they
had me do something really you know like
I I literally um uh stuffed envelopes
and then see the envelopes correct I
like ran out of saliva if you talk to
nonprofit they will not if you really
get them in an honest environment
they're like most of the time we don't
need volunteers yeah unless some
organizations like suit up might like
they actually set up to to utilize to
utilize volunteers but most are not um
and that's so the problem I'm looking at
like on the macro level is that
philanthropy does what I call a
feel-good model and and what I mean by
that is that if you're wealthy or if
you're a big company if you have
resources nonprofits will come to you
and say look at these Starving Children
look at this horrible problem aren't you
not a jerk and you have money can't you
help us and don't get me wrong that does
work some way in terms of getting
resources to places um but it's not it
treats a symptom it doesn't treat the
Cure and so like taking a big step back
yall like how do we look at this system
like how do we get how do we get beyond
the Feelgood um the average corate
Corporation gives 1% of their profits to
charity a year which is a lot don't get
me wrong like they're ging the fact
they're giving anything is is fantastic
but it's not fundamental to anything
they do and the reality is Coca-Cola
would give more to charity more than
1% if it helped them sell more Coca-Cola
or if it solved a problem or if it
solved a problem for them that was
helping themel um you know sell more
coke and that's not that's what it's
fundamentally set up to do so what I
what I'm trying to create here is a
shift from the Feelgood model to an
incentives model an efficacy model and
and yeah it's a good way to put it as
well
where cocacola has more incentive to
support great causes now that's tricky
and if you talk to folks that
work in the nonprofit industry there's a
certain Purity that they value where
it's like we are here to help and that's
it we don't care about making money we
care about doing good that is true that
is a good thing that said there's a way
to align these incentives especially if
you have government that's ineffective
Coca-Cola does care about education the
employees of that company and Executives
most of the time actually care about
living in a great world and having great
schools for kids and other kids to go to
so how do you align these incentives um
so that's landed with Samari he's like
what can there be for-profit incentives
of company to help nonprofit goals and
Ambitions and social causes yeah you get
that 1% up to 1.5 2% 3% it's a game
changer we're talking we talking about
billions of dollars yes so how do you do
this and then like you really think
about is like okay what does Habitat for
Humanity as a example nonprofit what do
they have to offer
Coca-Cola in terms of let's use another
one man let's use Humanity forward yeah
what does Humanity forward have to add
value to Delta or various Industries
various companies um in a incentive
aligned way and where we've landed is
what we found and what we found is what
do Charities have they have a lot of
supporters um and in many ways they have
passionate supporters they have the
ability to cut through the noise
differently so where Samar is right now
it's a a version of a market research
company um so what we're doing is we're
helping nonprofits raise money by
polling their supporters um so how it
works right now if you're a
nonprofit and uh you have let's call it
you have your your email list you have
your social media followers you have
your volunteer events etc etc instead of
asking them for money like you normally
do as or telling them about your awesome
work which you also do right um we give
you a custom email or custom survey link
that you can send and share with all
your supporters and for every person who
completes that survey the nonprofit
unlocks a donation uh donations vary
usually on average 1 to five bucks and
as a nonprofit you keep the data you can
we are essentially like an outsourced
donor research supporter research
service you get all this data cuz it's
yours um and you also get the money for
it and then the data is secure it's
Anonymous and what we are as a market
research firm we package all up
anonymously and put together market
research reports that your deltas and
coca-colas and Amazon and JD Powers Etc
are interested in paying for and we
share the profits of course with
nonprofits and if you think about this
the dream is you're Coca-Cola you're
spending $10 million on Market Research
every year can you spend 5 million on
that with Samar it's the same exact
market research but a chunk of it is
actually going to Charities so trying to
find that win-win so tonight's win if
you're a nonprofit We have some
nonprofits making th000 bucks a month or
so just to send out surveys that many of
them want to or should be doing anyways
so it's um it's it's early now we're
just starting we're onboarding our first
like 100 to 200 nonprofits but
we're pretty excited because we feel
like this is the first Runway or like
entry into aligning the incentives of
the for-profit and nonprofit
World hey YouTube glad you're enjoying
the podcast if you really like it hit
subscribe and then YouTube will notify
you every time we have a bang up new
guest thank
you